on this episode we talk about zip codes
we talk about valuations and we talk
about hustle
what else you ask questions and I answer
them
this is the askgaryvee show everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and you're
watching and listening to the askgaryvee
show episode number 32 little fun fact
about the number 32 32 is the number
worn by Josh Bush who's a New York Jets
safety who got caught yesterday off the
team
the Jets also played tonight against the
New England Patriots the team I hate
more than anything in the world before I
get into today's questions sorry Steve
so we'll have to do that again I want to
give a shout out to the person that gave
me I find it interesting that the person
that gave me the little prop for today's
show actually bat-channel did with the
whole crew here to get a shout-out on
the show I find that growth hacker but
also a little spammy she wants a shout
out and I'm not gonna do it the way she
thinks I'm actually gonna go to her
right now
d-roc get up I don't throw in your
curveball I know if you're listening
right now you have no idea what's going
on but that's just the way it's gonna
have to be so Nikki gave me the prop and
my question is did she give me the prop
because she's a good person or did she
give me a property because she just
wanted to get a shout out I love the
Nick someone I understand but wouldn't
you say it's a little selfish that
sounded a little bit like a humble brag
I mean you made it a point for them to
tell me that you wanted a shout out so
now we're giving you an extreme shout
out I mean where you going for the shout
out or are we going for it give me the
percentage breakdown of your love of the
mix versus your own personal selfish I
want a shout out on the show tell the
truth lying is the devil I don't lie
okay the Knicks are always over
everything else that's like what
percentage breakdown you copped out 95
for the mix yeah 5 for personal gain
there all right so 5% personal gain I'm
cool with that
all right dear occupy me because it's
right here and I don't want you to get
hurt oh you're gonna hook you're gonna
probably get it you like that at night
no no wedding now now with mellow in
tact here's a humble brag mellow once
sat in this exact seat actually I'm
freaked out the whole company that was a
lot of fun the other day all right
let's get into the questions Alex asked
Gary do you consider it possible the
hustle the way you do anywhere outside
of the United States Alex this is a
ludicrous question it is completely I
don't do we know where Alex is from and
you can look it up real quick while I'm
answering this question Alex this is a
ludicrous question this is this question
pisses me off so much that's starting to
start to show with it as Steve is
looking the thought and nature of like
people saying well America is an
entrepreneurial paradise is the same
conversation that's happening within
America of like to be great in tech you
need to be in San Francisco like no good
businesses are made outside of Silicon
Valley that is just asinine let me just
remind everybody that Facebook was
invented in Boston all right and the
home of the Patriots but like you know
like like I mean it's crazy for me when
people debate this of course you can
your country is not the variable of your
hustle my friend now the environment and
like entrepreneurship is glorified in
the US the UK wants to be more reserved
differently you know
China's got all its own version of
entrepreneurship yes does the
environment affect it of course my
parents growing up in Soviet Russia
where there was no business of course
they were affected by that but your
hustle your work ethic your drive is not
predicated on your zip code Tony asks
Gary what are your thoughts about people
that stay companies like Twitter uber
and snapchat are way overvalued in the
market Tony what's really interesting
about this question is I am one of those
people I grew up in the late and mid
2000s into the 2010s 11 12 13 thinking a
lot of things were overvalued I thought
we were at a little bit of a bubble in
2010 11 I've been proven to be extremely
wrong what I would tell you is is that
inflation happens I mean like that the
world changes like I'm starting to wrap
my head around the notion of wait a
minute maybe these things are
undervalued because you know the value
of a hundred million dollar company just
15 20 30 years ago was a far grander and
wealth just continues to exponentially
growing so you know I would say that
it's a double-edged sword there'll be
plenty of things overvalued tons but if
something is proven to have one and you
think is the future of infrastructure
Allah and uber where you can clearly see
them getting into FedEx and UPS
liens and other places you know plenty
of people have lost a lot of money by
thinking things were overpriced and I
want you to listen to that backwards one
more time and so rewind it whether
you're listening or watching you know a
lot of people have lost a lot of money
by thinking things have been overvalued
and of course there's the yin to that
yang and people have lost them betting
on overvalued things but when things hit
scale Amazon and eBay in the early days
of the internet where people thought
they were overvalued but the world
caught up to them be careful if the
world is catching up to something what I
mean by that is if you start watching
normal people doing things on some of
these platforms you're gonna see a scale
jump and so you are they overvalued if
there's a crash in the market right or a
terrace back in a major city can it be
overvalued of course but is that
temporary is the real question
and when I say temporary don't
misunderstand me is it overvalued and
it'll go down for a year but then go
back up because they're living in the
future while other things are not Amy
Hubbard asks for blogs just starting out
how do I get people to be interviewed
without being a big-name media company
Amy your question really means to me
which is how do I go out and get people
where I can take their brand equity as a
starting point for mine right like if I
can't interview garyvee and put it out
there some of his fans will come over
listen to that interview and then
they'll become aware of me so what
you're talking about is equity equity
leveraging arbitrage brilliant agree
with it if you look out and if you look
at pot you know for the people that are
listening if you look at podcast lame
that's how they all do it right like
that's what I did a bunch of those
interviews perming Jab Jab right hook
and then they're leveraging my name over
and over and over again to build
audience so it is a classic game there's
a dirty little secret
Amy people that have leverage and have
fame even if you call it Z level fame
like me they like to talk and so I'm
gonna tell you something that kind of
refers to question number one on this
episode which is the answer is hustle I
would just keep asking and asking and
asking
I would audit all the places that look
like you or kind of like you and look at
the people that have done interviews
there and when you start realizing that
I
and Tim Ferriss and Seth Godin like to
give interviews cuz we also like the
exposure we also have been successful
when we like to give back I loved a
couple years ago or last year of my
interview 365 day year thing where I
just gave people interviews that didn't
even have any audience because I was
giving back some don't want to give a
video interviews unless you're big
that's why you get nosed others do it
because they like to pay back to the
community and they remember grinding and
the person that gave them a break and so
very honestly I would ask and oh by the
way I got a real curveball for you and
this is for everybody listening
sometimes you need to ask the same
person 11 times and one could say that
you're being annoying but if you come
from a good place and you do it with a
prideful tack and you do it an
appropriate way and if you're actually
listening to what's going on in their
world
maybe Tim's got a new book coming out
maybe he redesigned his website maybe
he's got a new podcast those are times
to strike like a Cobra when they want
something and you want something then
interests align ncg asks what does one
do when you feel you have unique content
but not tapping into the right audience
or not gaining visibility Nicola this is
where you start looking yourself in the
mirror and deciding if you have business
development chops this notion that you
have the greatest content and it's not
finding its audience is romantic at
worst and audacious at best right and so
like to me what you need to look at is
are you capable of also building
audience for your content or are you
just the content provider and do you
need a partner who can go out and help
you do that or have you just lost all
sense of reality and your stuff is just
average
Gailen asks at what point do you just
get rid of a client because they're just
an all-around clown Galen this is a
funny question I think a lot of
vaynermedia employees are gonna have a
fun time with this question if they're
watching or listening I think that for
me I hold on for dear life
right like first of all business is
business I think one of the reasons
people recommend getting rid of clients
is they don't have the stomach for
adversity I actually can deal with the
negativity and it's business's business
and if they fire me then I deserve
to be fired but the notion of there are
clients to be fired it's right and a lot
of times it helps your business and so
it's about self-awareness so for me
Galen it's very late in the process like
almost borderline I don't know when they
take a knife and stab it through your
eye it might not be a good relationship
anymore but leak like that's literally
the level that I'm looking forward to
because I can handle it and it's not
slowing me down we've had plenty clients
that I think by all modern standards
should have been fired but I have not
and it has not hindered the growth
because yes there's some time and
attention put into that and even in the
world where we get lots of new business
there is value in retention there's also
moods sometimes look how about
relationships do you just get divorced
when a time comes tough you know the ebb
and flow do you just get rid of a best
friend because of a bad night I mean you
know do you get rid of a best friend
after six straight bad nights one could
argue yes but I think there's a lot
there that you may want to fight for it
so I think it comes down to
self-awareness a lot of people are not
capable of dealing with the conflict or
it brings them down to me I like to rise
to that challenge I like that game but
it comes down to my own self-awareness
of me as a leader and more importantly I
have to factor in the empathy of four
hundred other people and is it bringing
them down so cool I can stomach it but
as they're getting yelled at on the
phone by a client every single day is
that bringing them to a place where they
want to leave and so for me it's when
it's affecting other people that are in
my family that I value more and family I
mean my company that I value more than
the client itself that's what I'm
looking at it but then a lot of times
I'm trying to surround it or change the
account people of the people that have
more of my stomach and can handle it to
me that is the timing thanks for
watching episode 32 of the askgaryvee
show I really want to just take a quick
second and give a huge shout out and
then honestly you guys know how to roll
because it's been a lot of jabbing
coming in with a little bit of a hook on
this episode I really just want to thank
everybody who's been supporting my
transition to adding a podcast to that
to this whole genre and really just
supporting the show or 32 episodes in
you know this is not my first rodeo
I'm really enjoying it and so I want to
ask for some love on all the people that
are interested in subscribing to the
podcast on iTunes and all the other
places that were now playing with which
is a lot of fun are we confirmed
we're Alex where we at now at this point
we're on stitcher iTunes overcast yeah
we're going with them
meaning the some of the episodes haven't
been like play there so oh hustling
what's that SoundCloud India just cuz I
like showing new people in the room what
else I just wanted to catch you
off-guard
no that was it I know that's not even
your world but that was just fun for me
that was a personal haha for me um so I
really appreciate and the one thing I
guess I need to continue the flow is the
rating of it and by the way if that
ratings are won and you don't like the
show one-star and iTunes knock yourself
out and you know what noticing a lot of
you not subscribing on YouTube I need
that action as well so I appreciate you
allowing me a minute here to throw some
right hooks I hope they all land because
I'm hustling oh crap wait subscribe I
need subscriptions because I can't push
this many right hooks in social so
subscribe